[Music]
all right let's go to meredith in
lexington kentucky what's up meredith
hey how's it going excellent how are you
i'm i'm okay i'm sick today but i got um
i'm sorry opportunity to call in there
we go so what's what's the number how
can we help
uh okay so i have a it's a good problem
to have but um my boyfriend and i he's
more the financial guru but
we are having a tough time figuring out
what to do with all this money that i've
saved that is just sitting in the bank
right now we're debt free but we are
i've got about 100 to 120 000 just kind
of sitting
sitting in my bank account and we don't
really know what
what to do with it before george answers
this
can i ask you why
your boyfriend
is speaking into your money decisions
here's why
my job is almost exclusively
when things happen to people that nobody
thinks is going to happen
that actually happens to a whole bunch
of people
and so you're giving six figures worth
of autonomy to somebody
who has no
you can just walk at any time
so this is true why are you giving this
way just buy a ring together so do what
he's listening to this right i said we
did just buy a ring together so
hopefully we'll be fiance in the near
future i'm assuming you guys have you've
combined bank accounts
no we have not we just cohabitate okay
but it's not you kept saying we we we
all these decisions were a group
decision and so it made me think all
right the money's all entangled together
sure it's it's not it's not so meredith
because i'm talking about it as like a
future together yes i'm telling you this
because i love you i would not do
anything with him
at this point okay he does he does not
have a right to speak into your
financial situation and into your money
and i'm just telling you the number of
people we talked to
we were going to get married and so we
went ahead and did this we're going to
get married and we bought we bought a
ring we were engaged then we did this
and then he just walks that's totally
fair yes okay now he might be the
greatest guy in the world i'm not seeing
a bad guy i'm just saying you are the
one exposed right now
sure right
okay let's get to the financial part so
do you have any debt
no debt do you have an emergency fund
outside of this 120 or is this all the
cash to your name
that uh yes well
i guess some of that would be i do also
have another 20 and a high yield savings
okay let's call that your emergency fund
so let's say this other 120 is just for
fun
okay are you investing 15 of your income
yes the um my retirement account i
contribute 5 employer 10
so uh 15
and then
i
put in an additional 10 percent in like
roth iras and voluntary 403 b so you're
saying 15 of your income is going
towards retirement in some way shape or
form okay great
and where what about the house situation
we uh i just rent you're renting so so
it feels like the next plausible goal is
to get a house
for marriage sure sure yes now we don't
know what the future holds for meredith
and her boyfriend
so
you know i don't want you to make a
decision based on well he's moving into
this new house and this it gets weird
and please please whatever you do do not
put his name on the mortgage and don't
put his name on the on the deed
yeah if you're not married that is where
situations go sideways and hey real
quick george let's explain this here's
why um
if you put him on your deed and he's a
boyfriend and he decides to bail
the untangling of that is a mess
it's a disaster yeah if you're married
and one of you bails there's a legal
process to walk everybody out of that
and that's why we tell you you're
completely unexposed forget the morality
part forget the you go sunday school
i'm just saying purely it's not safe for
you because you have much less legal
protection see what i'm saying
and that makes sense one of the many
problems with cohabitation is you get
into a house and now he's paying you
half of the mortgage but he has no stake
in this house so he's not building any
asset now he's resentful and he walks
away and it just creates a a real
conundrum and so that is another issue
which one of the reasons uh we're
against that but i'm gonna let you do
you what i would do with this money is
just keep it in a high-yield savings
account because it sounds like this
decision whatever you do with this is
probably the next two years we're not
talking five years from now right
as far as the home purchase
right yeah i'm thinking probably in the
next three or so years okay if it was
like three four five plus years i might
put it in an s p 500 index fund and let
it grow at maybe eight nine ten percent
but because of the time horizon uh i
don't want your money locked up in the
stock market and then it's down and all
of a sudden you're like oh my gosh we're
getting married now and the money's
locked up and it's down i don't want to
sell while the shares are down putting
in a high yield savings account is going
to give you that you know what one and a
half to two percent right now
it's nothing special but it's gonna keep
your money safe keep it growing a little
bit and buy you time to make that
decision wisely so that's what i would
do if you need to make any other
upgrades like hey i'm driving a beater
car you can upgrade to a reasonable car
what's your income
uh 130 000. awesome meredith is crushing
it uh do you like what you drive right
now no issues good shape
oh i do i mean it is a 2010 honda civic
so i guess oh right on i don't know
60 000 miles on it so that's the problem
with the honda it's going to go for it
man you've done really well meredith i'm
proud of you i know he's got to get that
guy and if he likes it he better put a
ring on that's right
right